UFO sightings in Canada doubled in 2012
1981 sightings reported and of course
UFOs in case you don't know what a UFO
is it can be a dis nod Li shaped object
to large square triangular breath a ball
of fire or even objects shaped like
guitar picks I don't know which article
I got this room
alright let's in case I wasn't clear on
that let's take a look at some video of
us there were 1981 UFO sightings
reported in the country last year about
five a day that's more than twice the
number of reports in 2011 when there was
986 now the number of cases in 2012
completely eclipses all previous records
for the highest reports in one year
which was 1004 in 2008 right so there's
a little more info on the UFOs in Canada
but it has been happening in the United
States and all over the world as well so
first off guys do you believe in UFOs
have you had an experience with an
identified flying object what I like
about the description of UFOs is like it
could be a ball of fire yeah I'd hate to
be the alien who is assigned to drive
the ball this is just not comfortable
the shiny thing that seems nice the ball
the hair seems like a bit much yeah for
sure
Canadians I just like to say that those
things flying in the sky are called
airplanes we've had them down here for a
while just so you know that that's where
they are not a conspiracy theorist Fred
do you believe in UFOs and what do you
make of all these what do you make of
numbers jumping I don't believe in UFOs
although I have seen one and so I don't
believe it buddy what do you mean what
is driving out in the 60 to Palm Springs
very late one night and a UFO flew
overhead but I'm not so sure I didn't
see anything that was suspicious other
than it was discs like bright light in
the sky that didn't look how much more
suspicious what he wanted to be wouldn't
feel better if somebody had landed and
come out yeah I just I think that maybe
they did get one alien landing
and handed about 45 years ago Celine
Dion other than that I don't I don't
really believe in them yeah you're not
the only one who prepares jokes before
Sharla I really want the alien to just
land and go yeah I mean it seems to me
we're a tiny little rock next to a very
average star and we're here so why
wouldn't there be other planets and
civilized life out there or uncivilized
life doing some stuff do you think a lot
of the reports on this though are just
because we all have phones and we all
the videos and cameras you know ten
years ago if you saw something you just
go right to the mental institution now
you make a vine out of it yeah exactly
a lot of this is like there's that car
driving and looking out the window that
looked pretty weather balloon II or just
balloony to me so at least now we have
like video of these things in a video
itself is pretty rundown so it's like
now we can not trust a video the same
way we didn't trust some weird I'm
telling us they saw a UFO yeah do you
think in times when seems like the world
is a little upside down the economy's
not great and there's Wars and all that
kind of stuff but we want to believe in
stuff a little bit more just for just
for like our creative mind to feel like
there's something better than just this
thing that's so of course movies help at
books help create these ideas we have
images of aliens right now anyway just
thanks to Spielberg and a lot of other
people and so I think it's important and
to keep that imagination and and hope
for additional life as long as they
don't destroy the world like all the
summer movies are showing us yeah but I
I think it's good that people are aware
and you know the conspiracy theorists
abound with this because the all the
things that have happened in this
country that they think are creating
other life but from other planets but I
think it's I just think it's bunk and
this is it solar systems are too far
away I don't know how they get here we
don't think there's any life on any
other planet there's a real
you're debating yourself the answer to
how they get here is warp I don't know
if you've heard of war but they warp
here like a wormhole situation yes so
that's that's pretty simple friend yeah
yeah but since you know a lot about this
what's with the anal probing hey they
just I think they're gonna find there
that you can't find from questioning or
maybe they had one experience where they
did find something and so they just keep
going back to the same source but
there's a theory that the Stephen
Hawking even said which is like listen
if you see it alien don't talk to it
it's probably coming here because it is
depleted every resource on their planet
and they're looking for resources here
and if we were to do the same thing we'd
probably be like I'm sorry primitive
Society but like we really need clean
air at this point right okay so I'm a
big sci-fi guy and almost everything I
believe I learned from Star Wars do you
think there's any chance that if
civilizations were ever to collide and
meet each other that it wouldn't be a
case of what you're saying where you
know we have to destroy them because we
need their rocks to make oil or you know
an avatar situation is there any chance
that like better humanity or alien men
Amity will will work is there any chance
through this scenario and you want to
know my actual thought on it could be an
aberrant thing that I have gone through
things like dialectic in my head so it
has to be focus and embarrassing but it
has to be far enough along in the
development and Co discovery of alien
systems within each other where they've
had those experiences and determined
that they're terrible and so the same
way that we had were like there was like
the West and finally in you know moved
to the new world and ruined
civilizations and then the world got
smaller and so we start realized we
couldn't just blow each other up so it
has to be far enough where there's some
kind of alien UN and they find us at
that point in their development assuming
there's not some caveat for like really
primitive societies or it's like no one
will notice that we killed them and also
because our own UN here worked so well
that I think that's a pretty credible
and for some reason I believe it okay I
was being sarcastic